có cảnh đôi tùng giá hàng xam xử đồng ở hương viên.
Bây giờ, cho có số đẹp mình nằm và mình phân chia cho nó
từng có quốc lúa.
Thì nó thành một cái mọi người.
Hạo cảnh cho nó là những cái xúc quan của nó, nó có đôi đỏ, nó những cái dòng xú ý.
Cái hả, hãy quên trên trời hả,
và những cái hương á có lưỡa,
để cho thành đúng một cái môi, một cái đôi tụng.
Tạm mình thành quên thể đẹp như này.
Thông thếu có nào, thì tạm, nó ngay đúng không đầu tiên.
Hãy đuổi những cái tò là ăn chỗ lạc.
Tì nó mấy đủ, tây tạm nó đủ chêu cao để cho chúng ta làm được hùng kê khai nó cao.
Tì nó nó tổng 2 trăm bệm chợ.
Tìa có này thì nó rất bắt hoa,
từ tháng 3 cho đi tháng 3.
Bắt hồi lưỡa nào,
và đỏ ra 1 tự 1 hè xam của đồng.
Lức đó nó có khó trăm nhất,
và nó rất nhiều nó chính,
hôm 1 lâm đến 2 lâm.
Mình có định hình như cái rồi.
Còn sau khi nó thì mình khí tạo tạm mình muốn tạm.
Thì mình quên cái lạy nó mấy mất nó mấy lâm con.
Cái tạm dưới vào ra nó mấy dọc nó mấy.
Tạm chê nó thu nhỏ là phụ hợp,
hôm 1 cái cây,
hôm 1 cái khuên viên của chê mấy chào nó.
Mất rất nhiều con của đấy nữa.
Tự vẻ là mình chơi thể cái tát phòng nó có mấy đẹp đi thế này.
Mình cái tát,
cái bố cục,
cái được cả tử dụi chẹt.
Tạm tác,
rất là gần gủ rời cả người nông ra nó trí cho rời con.
Hôm cụ,
rời cả gần ý pháp nước ý đi làm cho
tình thần gủ rời xem rất là thải mám.
Tại vì thế này là tạm đại hạy là tạm,
tạm,
tạm.
Tạm,
tạm,
tạm.
Tạm,
không chứ mắt cái tều cảnh này thì nhìn vào đó mình cảm thấy.
Có một cái gì nó gửi,
cho mình tất cảnh cái cảm xúc của tụi thời.
Nói như một cái bức trang,
lùi loàn vùng vi.
Điám lại ở mình một cái không kí lập,
cái chất tế,
hơi kiám một chút.
Ná ở những cái đường ra y điện trang chi,
lếu như mà người nghĩa nhân,
làm được giấu cái phần dây điện như thế.
Thấy nó sẽ em rất là hoàn,
phải mang nhiều khi mà người ta so một năm,
làm được giộn giộn,
người ta về nha là ý.
Thôi mình hể tên,
thì cái nha làm thì cái người nha quý thế giọng người ta đi.